how how do you not uh crack and break  when others are trying to get you to pin  you against the person you're working  with how do you manage that see  frankly number one bush had really thick  skin so it didn't bother him and when it  doesn't bother the boss it tends not to  bother the staff now if it bothers the  boss or your boss is thin skin throws  stuff how do they do that why they  report that the man you're under  pressure a lot of sense yeah he wasn't  yeah so I didn't have to be  uh secondly I believe when the the most  beautiful thing about the White House  and I don't care what party you are yeah  is when you believe  it is so easy to fight and stand your  ground and you take the incoming you try  to pay attention maybe you'll learn  something from the incoming you can  rebutt it stronger learn you got a  vulnerability maybe we should address  this  but you take the incoming and you turn  it around because you believe  and that's how democracy should work